[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quel heureuse nouvelle que la réédition
chez galimar du texte de RAL d
fantastique maître Renard avec des
illustrations en couleur de Quentin
Blade ce duo d'auteur britannique a
réussi des merveilles d'impertinence et
de malice qui ont aisément franchi la
Manche et séduit le jeune public du
continent qu'on se souvienne par exemple
de James et la grosse pêche ou de la
potion magique de George bouillon
bogis buns et bean sont trois riches
fermiers plutôt antipathiques le premier
est gros le deuxème petit le troisème
maigre l'un élève des canards l'autre
des dindons et le troisième des dindes
quant à Maître Renard il est l'heureux
époux de dame Renard et le père de
quatre Renardo il nourrit très aisément
sa famille en chapardant alternativement
chez chacun de ces trois
fermiers comme dans toutes les histoires
il faut bien qu'un jour les méchants ser
LAAC des larsins de Maître Renard nos
trois bons hommes mettent au point une
tactique infaillible mais qui
heureusement se révélera inefficace pour
la plus grande satisfaction des lecteurs
et de leurs
[Musique]
parents